autour c'est encore un peu le chantier
le centre de loisirs mille clubs dédiés
aux 11-17 ans a inauguré ce week-end à
maurepas son nouveau bâtiment habillé de
bois construit à quelques mètres de
l'ancien préfabriqué au toit pyramidal
devenu inadapté même si le mobilier la
décoration ne sont pas prêts les jeunes
ont déjà pris possession des lieux on va
bénéficier de deux salles alors qu'on
avait juste une salle qui était pas
forcément super bien isolée donc là
c'est vraiment celle au confort quoi
absolue confort absolu avec une surface
au sol qui passe de 110 à 170 m² environ
et surtout une structure moderne
labellisé thx et hpe très haute
performance énergétique
chauffée par une pompe à chaleur
géothermique
grâce à ce nouvel aménagement de 900000
euros financés par la mairie et les
subventions du département et de la
région
les projets vont pouvoir mieux se
développer on a une moyenne en matière
de 30 35 jeunes par jour mais on
pourrait pas accueillir les 200 en même
temps même si on entre 200 et 300
inscrits mais ça nous permet en tout cas
de mieux structurer ces accueils et
surtout au niveau de l'accompagnement à
la scolarité de pouvoir faire des
espaces différents c'est un projet qu'on
a développé puis l'année dernière donc
il développe de plus en plus les
activités au sein du nouveau mille club
reprendront lundi 4 mars pour les
vacances scolaires des jeunes ont
d'ailleurs profité de l'inauguration
pour s'inscrire la carte jeune
maurrassien coûte 6 euros 75 par an pour
les séjours et sorties thématiques le
tarif est évalué selon une grille
tarifaire en fonction des quotients
familiaux un atelier d'initiation au
graffiti avec un professionnel est
prévue mercredi 13 mars certains ont
déjà commencé